I'm going to start with I've seen the
whole series uh it's fantastic I'm
really happy that it was made deals with
incredibly important subject matter I'm
assuming that's the reason why you got
invited or was it just because you saw
Scott Burns's name on the screenplay uh
maybe a little bit of both I mean I I
read the the two episodes that Marshall
is in and like fell in love with the
story of that of just that particular
character so yeah I mean it was the a
the kind of art I want to make that is
is trying to do something greater than
the sum of its parts and then also
just a great script yeah this is also
the kind of show that I want to promote
because it deals with incredibly I mean
it's the most important stuff that we
could possibly deal with you know yeah
yeah it's funny I've been thinking about
this a lot today while speaking about it
is just that it's it is
it feels a little silly to be like to
create a big splashy show to be like
climate change exists which feel like
table Stakes but that's the problem it
is table Stakes but we don't we're not
forced to look at it a lot it just is
the world that we're living in and so I
think one of the particular
things that science fiction is great at
is that extrapolating ourselves a little
bit like moving a little bit ahead of
our current moment and then being like
look at yourself look at the choice that
you're making and like this is this is
the the consequences of those actions
and that's something that this genre is
so good at so yeah it's a it's a good
use of it no completely also the the
show does a really great job at focusing
on real people like just people living
their lives as well as the big issues
that like you know the world leaders are
trying to tackle all in one Series yeah
yeah yeah I think um that was my
favorite thing about about it really was
just like these very these personal
stories
um and then some of the folks we're
looking at are also world leaders you
know like so but we're still involved in
their personal drama some of them are
scientists but we're still involved in
their personal drama like there's
people's jobs and there's the world that
we live in and then there's people
everybody's just people and we all just
you know we all experience so much of
the same things yeah one of the things I
think in in one of your episodes I think
it's just it's a very powerful shot of
the congregation
um sitting there all wearing boots
because the foundation is flooded and
that's just the future that's coming
yeah I love that so much
um yeah the that that image and that you
know not too distant future if you're if
you're at if you're at what now is about
sea level like that's not an
unfathomable thing it's uh and it's
happened in some places in the world
already so like you know
um so yeah that Miami would be in that
position is not uh
is something that
building developers they're already
thinking about right like that land is
becoming unusable because it is going to
be underwater so like the you know what
I think another thing that the series
kind of subtly hints at is that like
capitalism is a few steps ahead of
policy in these discussions always right
because like it is a it is a better
machine and so it is like
those are the people out there doing the
research being like hey this is going to
be underwater now so if you're going to
sell it you better sell it fast it's
gonna be way harder to sell this when
it's underwater yeah that stuff is scary
I think about the fact that I will never
move to Florida even if you paid me you
know just for many reasons but that's
one of them
um yeah well I definitely have to touch
on real fast your scene partner I
believe her name is neska
um yet she is fantastic how wonderful is
she yeah and not only is she fantastic
but the writing between the two of you
is just next level and it's really
shining a light I mean it's just so well
done can you sort of talk about her
performance and the writing of those
scenes I mean yeah obviously like those
scenes were what got me to do the fast
so the scripts totally brilliant um and
it does this thing where she is leading
you know like it is Marshall is is at
the at this somewhat apathetic moment in
his life until nesca comes until yeah
until she comes along and like is
is starts challenging him
um but she does lead those scenes so you
need an actor who can do that uh at at a
very young actor who can do that and she
is so wonderful she yeah I mean like day
one I was like oh yeah it is her senior
so that's definitely her scene I'm
definitely along for the ride uh and so
yeah it I I had so much fun to work with
and we got to you know you know there's
the whole like dream ballet situation of
it too like we got to do a lot of fun
stuff together which is also great was
it in the script that they were gonna
have you sing or was it once you got
cast Scott's like you know I'm thinking
about a song I honestly don't remember
yeah I can't remember I don't I don't
know if it was in there initially but
before
by the time I got there I knew it was
gonna happen right it wasn't like sprung
on me like by the time I showed it but I
think we had some conversations about it
where he was like hey what would you
think of I I think
but yeah it's hard for me to remember
which came first I'm not sure how much
of the series have you actually seen
I've Just Seen I've actually just seen
the first three I've read a few of the
other ones beforehand but like yeah I
haven't seen the Finnish versions I'm
very curious I mean I wanted to ask you
what your favorite storyline was of the
upcoming ones that you're not a part of
but you haven't seen it yet I will just
say that it's kind of fantastic just
throwing that out there you know
um listen I'm just about out of time
with you um obviously like everyone I've
actually heard some good things about
The Little Mermaid movie
um through my little you know Rumor Mill
of Disney
um what does it mean for you to be part
of that project I mean I I'm sort of
stunned I was stunned that they wanted
me to be part of it and then uh every
moment of working on it was like whoa
this is what I get to do right now
um but yeah I I am also eagerly
anticipating the release of it but what
I can tell you is that
uh Hallie is unbelievable I know that
because I was next to her a lot of the
time while she while she was learning
that role and uh yeah she's the
is really phenomenal my last thing for
you um what are you actually filming
this year I'm a really big fan of your
work and I'm just curious oh man I mean
some some stuff I'm about to go shoot
that I don't know where I am with aloud
to being talk talk loud to talk about it
but like movies back to doing some
movies which would be cool and then uh
yeah season two of blind spotting is
coming out uh very soon middle of April
so yeah that's exciting actually gonna
go Premiere the second season at South
by Southwest end of next week uh so
that's that's very exciting
um yeah writing a bunch of things it's a
new clipping album coming out in the
fall like yeah a lot of it's gonna be a
good year I think
sometimes it all happens at once uh I
won't be seeing you at South by but I'm
really looking forward to the second
season and truly I wish you nothing but
the best
um and if we can help promote your stuff
on collider please let me know we'll
reach out man thank you so much cool
have a great day and congrats on the
series for real appreciate it thank you
thank you